you just described is a quid pro quo it
is funding will not flow unless the
investigation into the into the
Democratic server do we do that all the
time with foreign policy we were holding
up money at the same time for what was
it the northern triangle come from
countries we were holding a beta at the
northern triangle countries so that they
so that they would change their policies
on immigration but by the way and this
speaks to Addis piece to import l'm
sorry
this speaks to important point because i
heard this yesterday and i can never
remember the gentleman who test was
mckinney the guy is that his name for me
i don't know i'm he testified yesterday
and if you go and if you believe the
news reports okay because we've not seen
any transcripts of this the only
transcript i've seen was someone's
testimony morning this morning if you
read the news reports and you believe
them what a mckinney say yesterday well
mckinney said yesterday that he was
really upset with the political
influence in foreign policy that was one
of the reasons he was so upset about
this and I have news for everybody get
over it there's going to be political
influence in foreign policy I'm talking
mr. Karle that is going to happen
elections have consequences and foreign
policy is going to change from the Obama
administration to the Trump
administration and what you're seeing
now I believe is a group of mostly
career polity of uric rats for saying
you know I don't like president Trump's
politics so I'm gonna participate in
this which on to their that they're
undertaking on the hill elections do
have consequences and they should and
your foreign policy is going to change
Obama did it in one way we're doing in a
different way and there's no problem
with that